[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nous venons de faire
un beau voyage
nous avons ramené totaux rémy et fanfan
chez leur maman qui les a trouvés
superbe une grande et puis on a vu
beaucoup d'autres petits enfants de
toutes les races et de toutes les
couleurs qui mangent bien leur soupe et
qui vont se coucher bien sagement chaque
soir n'est ce pas nounours ah ça oui
patron c'était mignon c'est petit mais
je préfère tout de même nicolas et pas
problème j'ai hâte de les revoir à tron
descend vite nounours effet leurs deux
gros baiser de ma part et pop
bon le jeune homme bon sport buchler au
fond qu'est ce que tu nous as rapporte
égal au plein de choses d'abord c'est
jolie petite fleur que rémi toto et
fanfan ont recueilli pour vous dans la
montage parce qu'elle aidera mama sera
sûrement très contente
et puis deux pros descente ce qu'ils
sont gentils ils ont fait pour vous
tenue merci non au regard
ça c'est la patte de rémy mais oui ils
vont venir annonce chicana on les aime
beaucoup tu sais cher petit choeur
d'hommes
oh j'oubliais le principal voilà deux
jolies pain d'épicés celui-là il est
pour moi j'ai fait cela pour moi c'est
ma soeur emilie à qui les a faits pour
vous c'est une fille pâtissière là moi
je mets les flammes et mama gaza comme
ça vaduz annonce on va leur écrire
athènes veut ça leur fera oui ils m'ont
plu six mois on avait fait des bauges et
ans il était tellement propre allons les
enfants je vous accompagne tout au tout
pourquoi tu veux tu dénonces les voyages
ça me donne envie de dos cette guerre
julien mukala vrai
[Musique]
mais tu viens m'annonce tu tu repars pas
de nouveau en voyage au lot c'est trop
fatiguant
bonne nuit les petits la jette à la
lumière
bunning et niort monnaie à demain venus
d'écoles a connu pauvres mal
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain les petits amis nous sommes très
heureux d'être revenu vouloir ah oui on
est bien heureux mais tuba une ourse
allons vite nous coucher nous aussi
bonne nuit les petits faites de beaux
rêves
ce que je vais en faire des bourgs
heures cette nuit patron bonne nuit à
demain demain au body
[Musique]